you know we asked you well for I have a
a one or two geek questions because I'm
a hack guitarist what was the guitar you
saw as a kid that blew your mind was
there well my father played a Flying V
and uh he had a
1966 or something Flying V yeah and um
purple
very cool with uh like an 1890s Indian
Head silver dollar which people used to
put in the back of flying Beast because
as a counterweight because the
headstocks are so heavy the guitar
always wants to rotate forward yeah and
uh and uh so my dad high on whatever he
was on you know with the very 70s
mustache that was the guitar you know
were you allowed to touch no I was not
okay I was not he forbid me to touch the
instrument wow
um and uh so I was only allowed to look
I have to say that the couple of times
I've
strapped on a Flying V I found it a very
uncomfortable experience and not
something it is very uncomfortable and
so then what did you did you move on to
a Les Paul my father got me a a Korean
made Les Paul copy as it's known in the
business so it looks like a Les Paul but
it's some badly made one
um I had that I painted it black I sold
it to a drug dealer and then uh I had a
Fender Mustang that my father gave me I
played that for a while but it had very
um weak pickups couldn't get the grunge
sound and then Jimmy Chamberlain uh
showed up one day with a uh 1974 yellow
Strat uh yellow definitely not my color
but Richie Blackmore did play that
guitar so that was okay and Jimmy said
I'll sell it to you for 270 dollars
right even at the ton of an odd number
right yeah yeah
I later found out because that's how
much he needed for rent yeah it had to
be for something specific and then and
then fast forward 20 years I'm walking
down the street in Chicago and a guy
pulls me aside says do you still have
that yellow guitar and I said no that's
the one that got stolen I don't know if
you heard that story somebody found it
27 years later and came back to me but
at that they want to resell it to you no
no this guy pulled me aside and said do
you still have that that guitar right
um and I said
no and he goes but she got it from Jimmy
Chamberlain right yeah yeah he said how
much did he charge you for it oh and I
go 270 he goes yeah he stole that guitar
for me oh Jesus okay he wasn't mad
because he was he loved Jimmy it was
some weird story like kids story where
Jimmy had stolen the guitar and sold it
to me for rent money
and that was the that was the guitar
that I played on the band's first
records and they got that guitar got
stolen some sort of weird karmic thing
came back 27 years later it's gonna re
it's gonna reappear in your life oh you
did get it yeah a gentleman uh out of
Nashville somebody contacted him and he
bless his heart
got the guitar back he obviously played
somebody didn't ask me for any money it
just gave me the guitar oh that's great
after 27 years I like that that's cool
had it been altered much no
um surprisingly not I remember
very well that the first
electric guitar I got was I think I paid
600 for it and it was 1985.
and that was an incredible amount of
money that's a lot of money that's a lot
yeah uh what what where's your guitar
well that's it it was a 63 Gretch I'm
sorry 64 Gretch Tennessean oh nice and
so actually for the money it turned out
to be a amazing investment it's worth a
lot now do you still have it I have it
hanging up on the wall behind me and
um
I had it at Saturday Night Live
when uh George Harrison stopped by to
say hi to all of us after a night of
partying with Lauren and it was in my
office and it's the exact same year and
model that George played on the tour and
for a second I thought about running
down and getting that guitar and showing
it to him and then I thought don't be
that guy yeah
so that's one of those judgment calls I
think I made the right call yeah I think
uh I think at that moment that was the
right call because I
you know to a to a geek like me it was
like oh this is perfect I'll show George
the same make and model guitar and he
would have seen uh a kid with some acne
who was undernourished and a big pile of
hair on his head shoving a guitar at him
when you know he could probably open a
closet at home and 700 gretches will
fall out so wanna hear a quick funny
story no I don't have time for that
okay let's move on
yes please so uh Jack Bates plays in the
pumpkins he plays bass his father is
Peter hook of Joy Division and New Order
thing
and uh they were touring and they had
rented a Vox
amp and the amp blew up it was from a
rental company
so they knew not to just take the amp
back to the rental company they took it
somewhere to be repaired before they
returned it to the rental company anyone
when the guy took the chassis off they
found scratched into the Mainframe
George Harrison I forgot to say it was
one of Georgia's amps that had been
stolen in 68 that he'd played on like
revolver
and people thought it was lost forever
and so then it was returned back to the
rental company who then sold it for you
know some ungodly sum but it's a cool
story I had I was in uh Nashville and
there was a famous guitar shop that I
was touring
ruins yeah I remember I spent a few
dollars well they tried to get me to
spend a few dollars at one point they
showed me because I'm a Buddy Holly
fanatic and they showed me an amp that
belonged to Buddy
and they were showing it to me and then
they took it off and they showed me
where buddy had put his you know written
and then did you buy it
well I was fascinated by it and they let
me plug it in and I got to play that'll
be the day uh on a Stratocaster through
that amp and so I was just
pure joy was coming out of my pores and
then they told me um how much it was
they wanted for it and I realized I
could get this I mean buddy owned it but
other than that it's a Fair to Midland
old sure you know and uh amp and I could
get that or I could put one of my kids
through college and so I think I made
the wise decision I bought I bought it
at auction
so in 1982 I went to see uh Judas Priest
play and it was at a racetrack which
eventually burned down and when I was in
there it felt like a fire trap it was
one of those things where you're looking
around and go if something goes wrong
here I'm gonna die yeah but it's Judas
Priest yeah and so what a way to go
not bad yeah Judas Priest in 82 not not
a bad way to go so I bought
the pedal board the KK down Downing was
using that day and the amp that he was
playing those came up for auction so I
bought those
that's cool so it's like a cool like you
know it's like you can call me if you
tell me at 14 or something by the way
one day you're going to own that amp and
that pedal word from that guy who you
adore yeah not a bad gig right no it's
like in a weird way you're closing some
mystical Loop yes right that's how I
feel that's
that's why I I I would be happy if you
had bought them because there's
something that happens when you do stuff
like that it makes no sense at all but
it sort of confirms some other thing
yeah so I'm telling you that you're weak
[Laughter]
yeah my only real regret in that regard
was I was at an auction once but we were
shooting something at a rock and roll
auction
Elvis Aaron Presley's library card from
Humes High School came up on the Block
and I was busy trying to position the
cameras and wasn't listening and then I
looked and they were like going once
going twice and they didn't get the
amount they wanted so they took it off
the auction and I don't know where it is
now
but I would have paid a lot of money to
have had that in my wallet for the rest
of my life yeah and uh missed it and so
if it's whoever owns it let me know
because you name the amount and I'll pay
it
um less than Buddy Holly's amp no no
it's all different now my kids don't
need to learn how to read